hello everyone and welcome to today's
seminar webinar diabetes and the
clinical laboratory i am marie stone of
lab roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by abbott we encourage
you to participate today by submitting
any questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits window at the bottom of your
screen to obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
professor gary john has played a central
role in establishing hb a1c diagnostic
testing and guidelines worldwide
he has chaired several committees within
the ifcc
including the hba1c working group who
developed a standardization procedure of
hba1c measurements
he has worked closely with numerous
national and international diabetes
organizations and has been an advisor to
the who
professor gary john will now begin the
presentation
that's kind introduction
uh and i'm today i'm going to talk to
you in some depth
what himalayan sea analysis
and its clinical utility
these are my disclosures
that this is a program that is supported
by abbott
although i don't represent abbott in any
way whatsoever
at some learning objectives hopefully by
the end of this lecture we'll be able to
understand the testing method principles
being global may want to see
we will review with you the
methodologies
and we'll discuss it as a diagnostic
monitoring tool
and i will go in some depth into quality
specifications
i will
just maybe have a chance to overview
guidelines for diabetes testing
measurement science
and diabetes
have a long relationship interlinked
over many many years and centuries
indeed going back to the middle of the
1600s
a british physician and biochemist
called willis
described the urine collected from
diabetics as having a sweet taste
indeed he associated this with good
fellowship and guzzling down of wine
a century later
a dobson went slightly further
city more scientific and he isolated a
dry residue
from the urine collecting diabetics
and he said it looked and tasted like
brown sugar
luckily something we don't have to do
anymore
glucose remained the mainstay
of diabetes testing
for many centuries
and it wasn't until
a chance finding by raba
back in 1968
who described an abnormal hemoglobin
in the blood of patients with diabetes
that this came
that this fraction came to the interest
of the clinical fraternity
we now know a cause this is not an
abnormal hemoglobin but indeed is
glycated hemoglobin or hemoglobin a1c
i don't intend to go into biochemistry
any great depth
but we need to know that this is a
non-enzymatic reaction and followed look
typically the law of mass action
things to remember about this reaction
is a two-stage reaction
it goes through a relatively
quick reaction that a very slow amador
rearrangement
overall the process is slow
and continuous
this reaction continues throughout the
lifespan
of a red cell
and needs to remember that glucose binds
preferentially
to the internal valine of the hemoglobin
but the glucose will bind to other sites
of the hemoglobin molecule
if liquid binds to the n-terminal valine
then it creates a charge difference on
the hemoglobin
if glucose by elsewhere on the
hemoglobin molecule it does not create a
charge difference
and it's often said that hemoglobin c
represents the previous three to four
months
of glucose control within the individual
and that is true to a large extent
but because it's a continuous process
and continue to turn over
what we take what we are seeing is that
a blood sample collected only a patient
it's like a hemoglobin hidden group may
want to see it that is measured reflects
about half
of the of the measured hemoglobin a1c
is reflected within that month
so
50 of the effect of that result is what
you see within that month
about 25 the previous month
and only about 6 percent
is reflected four months previous
so yes hemoglobin a1c does reflect the
previous three to four months but the
major effect on the results is what you
see in the previous one month
so
what happens when hemoglobin is glycated
as i said if it's located at the end
terminal valine it creates a slight
charge difference between
glycademoglobin and non-glycate
hemoglobin
there is a structural difference
obviously it now has a glucose attached
to the structure and there is a chemical
difference
and each of these have been used to
actually
devise methods for measuring hemoglobin
a1c
let's first look at charge difference
cation exchange chromatography is
probably the most widely known of the
methods the measurement globally wanna
see it's been around for a long time and
there are many many different
manufacturers that produce instruments
information hemoglobin a1c using iron
exchange cation exchange chromatography
and their numerous advantages this
method but also several disadvantages
it was the original method described for
measuring hemoglobin a1c and it is well
proven
and there are many many manufacturers
that is a good or a bad thing
he has good separation
but be careful that is very much
manufacture dependent
it identifies common hemoglobin variants
and excludes them from analysis
again be careful is manufacture
dependent
i standardize the ifc reference
measurement procedure something i'll
come back to later but again be careful
depend on the manufacturer
is interfered with a number of factors
again depending on the manufacturer so
yes probably the most widely known of
the methods
but it has it it has advantages also it
has its disadvantages
still on
uh charge separation we have capillary
electrophoresis
this is
electro electrophoresis is um similar to
unexchanged chromatography but then in a
column
uh
or in a capillary rather than the column
this again has a number of advantages is
this does show excellent separation
good accuracy and precision
but it has disadvantages like there
are many manufacturers that actually
have variable quality
it does not have a stat ability
and one has a question whether it's
clinically needed or not
and it has a slow throughput therefore
several capillaries have to use in
parallel
to cope with the throughput required for
clinical purposes
they grown structural difference
that the glucose attached to the
hemoglobin
and acetic chromatography makes use of
this glucose
the boronic acid of the infinity column
recognizes the cyst dial associated with
glucose
and loosely binds it on the column
so that any glucose any hemoglobin has
got glucose attached to it will stick to
the column
and hemoglobin without glucose just
washes straight through
but the main difference here is that
this recognizes
hemoglobin and is located at any part of
the hemoglobin molecule not just the
n-terminal valine
[Music]
do not mention hemoglobin a1c as such
a calibration will bring it back to
hemoglobin everyone's seen
this again has number of a good
advantages it shows good accuracy and
precision
easy sample handling no interference
from the blue variants
and no difference from non-glucose
addicts
but it does have disadvantages
there is some some bachelor batch
variability in gel quality
it requires a dedicated analyzer as does
hplc and um
and capillarysis
but it does not identify abnormal
hemoglobins
and if that's important
and we can discuss this possibly any
questions
then this system will not show that uh
abnormal abnormality up
equal immunology
amino acid is a system which detects the
glucose bound to two three or four amino
acids
it's been run for some time now and it's
quite amazing to think that it could
raise an antibody to something where the
only difference is the glucose moiety
again it has number advantages and
disadvantages it shows good accuracy and
imposition
but there's very analyzer dependent
the better accuracy and decision is
found if it is dedicated as an analyzer
used to measure it rather than on the
main chemistry analyzer within a
laboratory
it has easy sample handling
and because it only detects
about three or four amino acids there's
no interference from the ingrown
variants apart from the very rare amino
acids are very rare variants that change
amino acids depositions one to three
no interference from non-glucose addicts
and can be done on routine chemistry
analysis rather they say that results in
poorer performance than it is done on
its dedicated analyzer
again it does not recognize hemoglobin
variants
and finally
chemical differences
this is probably the most recent
methodology you find out on the market
enzyme immunoassay
this uses a
a protease to cleave
so the
two amino acids
um creating a fructose dye
peptide
and then uses this enzymatic
reaction to produce color
again this shows him
incredibly good accuracy and indecision
easy sample handling and like
immunoassay has no interference immune
group and variants apart from those of
positions number one or two
it is interfered from non-glucose
addicts and can be done on routine
chemistry analysis
and it can have a large sample
throughput
disadvantages are very either small but
possibly we are still learning how this
asset works over long long-term external
quality assessment
it does not identify hemoglobin variants
and it also means putting whole blood
onto your main analytical system
but overall there are a number of
different means of measuring the group
may want to see
one is not better than the other it
depends on your situation you choose the
method that best suits the laboratory
that you are serving
so getting the correct hemoglobin a1c
result
why is this so important
well
if we look here at data from the uk pds
is in type 2 diabetics
we could see that a change in only one
percent hemoglobin are going to see a
very small
improvement in global neo1c it has been
a 21
decrease in deaths related diabetes
a 37
decrease in micro vascular complications
and a 14
decrease in associated mycar lymphomas
so we have to have methods that can
well differentiate
a one percent change in hemoglobin a1c
so there's a need to standardize
and why was this
but if we look at the cap surveys going
back to the early 90s 1990s
you can see there's a huge variation
in the results being obtained with
different methods
not only with it results targets being
different and issued poor accuracy but
we also see poor imprecision
if you look in the uk the same time you
know things didn't look good
the laboratory things are even worse
this shows here between laboratory
agreement for different methods used in
the clinical laboratories in a large
region within the uk
as you can see here
that depending which laboratory you went
to
you could actually have a result in one
lab of four point three percent in
global negligency
or you want to lab down the road
and you get a result of nine point four
percent hemoglobin i want to see
there is no standardization
and when we're trying to look at
differences of one percent to see these
large clinical differences you can see
here that these results
have little or no clinical relevance
so this lack of global standardization
resulted in a number of national schemes
being introduced
and probably the most widely recognized
was the national glycohemoglobin
standardization program now a course
called ngsp
there's also the swedish scheme and the
japanese standardization program
but the major problem
of these national schemes were that
there was no reference method
there was no primary refs material
and no traceability
what does this mean
well the ngsp
setup was a wonderfully conceived
project
it resulted in a core primary reference
laboratory
running a
highly optimized hemoglobin a1c method
the cprl was then used to standardize
secondary reference laboratories
and the second reference laboratories
were then used to calibrate
routine methods that we would use in the
laboratory
the primary reference method being used
at time was it was a optimized hplc
described by goldstein little at hour
which is produced and published
so
in the in the mid 1980s
and is now recognized as having
significant positive bias due to
interference
so as this is not it does not have a
reference mesh procedure this is
harmonization
not standardization
what do i mean by this well
very simply
if we look at a dart board
are we throwing data dart board
and we were throwing them and we've got
good grouping together in other words we
get all the results to be the same
but if you're aiming for the bullseye
we get results wrong
this is harmonization all the results
are harmonized to a given value or given
standard
it is not the true value
but if you throw in the dots again
aiming for the bull and you have the
same kind of grouping
then this is
standardization you would you're getting
the right result
but harmonization does have an effect if
you go back and look at the same cap
survey we can see now that harmonization
has resulted in those mean values
getting far closer
to what you expect
in precision it remains poor
but the target values the accuracy is
getting better
so it might not be true standardization
but harmonization has helped
but the ifcc has recognized there was a
need for global standardization of
people globally want to see
and produce a working group to look at
this
and over the years this working group
has produced a standard method
and this method that we we tried to
produce was based on metrological
requirements
and their levels of metallurgic
requirements we need to actually
understand we need to identify first and
measure and what are we going to measure
a single a single measurement is
required
we develop reference measurement
procedures that accurately precisely
measures the measure and
you have breath of laboratories refs
material and need to be traceable
let's look at the measure and first
we decided the measurand
will be hemoglobin
with glucose attached to the n terminal
valine
this is called hemoglobin beta chain
blood
n one deoxy fractals one aisle
hemoglobin beta chain
or
hemoglobin a1c
is a measure and there's a single
single entity a glucose attached to the
n-terminal building
also it was recommended that we measure
this property
in s i units
and the si unit for hemoglobin a1c is
millimole per mole
millimole of hemoglobin a1c
per mole of hemoglobin a naught plus
hemoglobin a1c
we developed a reference measured
procedure that accurately measures
hemoglobin
is not interfered with but any other
property that may be there
and if we are to develop a
reference-based procedure we need a
standard to calibrate this reference
measured procedure
this is what we've done we have produced
pure hemoglobin a1c and pure hemoglobin
a node
and these are used in the reference
measured procedure
which is based on
enzymatic cleavage
and then measurement
following uh hblc and mass spec
or hblc and capillary
electrophoresis
both giving identical results
both are highly specific hemoglobin a1c
and not interfered with by other
fractions
this method is not a method we would use
in the routine laboratory
this method is only used in reference
laboratories that are used to assign
values
to standards which we would use in a
clinical laboratory
we need to identify reference
laboratories
and now this reference mesh procedure
is used in a large number of
laboratories
worldwide
every single one of these labs
that runs the reference mission
procedure
and every one of these laboratories has
input into
assigning calibration values to
standards that we would use within our
clinical laboratories
not one laboratory
is used to assign value all laboratories
are
and that leads to a very high level of
accuracy
so we now have a method that we know
measures hemoglobin a1c specifically
is used in a large number of
laboratories around the world
all of which are used to assign values
standards that we use in the clinical
laboratory
and it is now traceable
we now have an unbroken chain of
traceability
from the patient sample that we measure
in routine laboratories
back to the primary reference material
which are banked at the irm
so we now have a stable
traceable
method that we can use to assign our
patient samples to
i will look at the consensus statement
produced by the american diabetes
association
the european associative studies of
diabetes
international diabetes federation
and the ifcc
it says that the ifcc of residence
system which i've just described to you
represents the only valid anchor to
implement standardization of the
hemoglobin a1c measurement
and now
we are lucky that all major instrument
manufacturers calibrate their systems
using standards provided by the ifcc
abortion network
so we now have a system whereby we've
got long-term stability
and accuracy
so we can measure outpatient samples
with a high level of
confidence
and now we look at the standardization
we can see that standardization as a
result is an even better
outcome for our standards
the
uh the mean results now lie far closer
to target values show that accuracy has
improved
and with accuracy improving we are
finding that imprecision is also
improving
the question that one or two people ask
me as well is why a hba1c results from
ifc standardization different to those
from ngsp harmonization
why is a hemoglobin a1c of seven percent
not the same as a hemoglobin c of 70
millimoles per mole well that goes back
to looking at the ngsp value compared to
the ifcc calibration
we see here the lines
of of a relationship between the ngsp
the japanese system and the swedish
system
and they call it well
but if we look a bit more closely at the
bottom end we see that there's a
difference about 1.5 to 2 percent
hemoglobin a1c
with the ngsp values being higher
and that reflects the non-specific
interference
that we see in the ngsp reference method
and this is taken into account when we
calculate
the
values and relate them from the ngsp to
the isc
so yes there is a relationship there but
because of this non-specific
interference results are not the same
if you won't know the clinical aspects
of hemoglobin a1c
from the dcct
um
trial of many years ago now
we used to see that as he would only
want to see values increased
so did the rate of retinopathy
nephropathy neuropathy and microorganism
and as you can see the higher the
hemoglobin a1c the greater the increase
in these conditions
resulting from diabetes
if i go to the other way
if you were able to lower the hemoglobin
a1c we could decrease
the levels of these conditions
as you can see from this graph just
decreasing by small amounts
had remarkable improvements
in patients in this case with type 1
diabetes but also type 2 diabetes
so what target should we look for
well the american derby association the
ada
the european association study of
diabetes the eesd
and the international diabetes
federation the idf have all issued the
recommendations
but they differ
the ada and the esd
have target hemoglobin a1c values of 53
millimoles per mole or 7
but the idf
who focus more on um
postpartum hype post plantar
hypoglycemia
have a target value of 48 millimoles or
more or 6.5
quite different
in the uk nice guidelines national
institute for clinical excellence
suggests that we measure hemoglobin a1c
in type 2 diabetics and three to six
months the intervals
while the heat while the glycemia is
changing and possibly six months the
intervals once glycemia is in a stable
state
and that we use
uh hemoglobin a1c has calibrated the
ifcc standardization
and we have a target of 48 millimoles
six point five percent for diabetes for
type 2 diabetics the whole always their
own drug uh treated diet uh sort of uh
drug
um treatment then
in case of hypoglycemia we aim for a
slightly higher value of 53 millimoles
or more or seven percent
i don't expect you to go look at this
thing for detail but we then produce
very
detailed guidance of what to do if
valleys fall above this
our type one diabetes we suggest that
hemoglobin once each measure is three to
six months
consider more often
in adults with type of diabetes if the
glucose still is suspected to change
rapidly
and again the method should be
calibrated to the ifcc
because of the associated long-term
risks
with type of type 1 diabetes a target
level of 48 millimoles or more or 6.5
percent
is attempted to be aiming for
but
as
as we now know we should agree
individualized hemoglobin a1c with a
target for each adult with type 1
diabetes and this will differ from
individual to individual depending on
this situation
again worldwide there's a huge global
burden associated with diabetes
back in 2011 there were
366 million people with diabetes
by 2030
less than 10 years away now isla has
risen to 500 not million
speed of increase this is already
suggested visa part in this by 2030
but possibly the most worrying thing
is that about half of people with
diabetes globally are undiagnosed
this is a major impact on individuals
and we have to try and address this
currently
we are treating diabetes possibly too
late
this is this is type 2 diabetes there's
a move away from normality
to dysglycemia into front diabetes
now we are currently diagnosing
patients with diabetes at about this
point
at this point they've already
significantly had increasing
microvascular complications
but possibly more importantly there's
been a huge increase in macro vascular
complications
ideally we should be finding patients
far earlier so you can intervene earlier
and hopefully stop development of these
complications
which is why in 2011 the who recommended
that hemoglobin a1c be used to diagnose
diabetes
and they suggested is a cut point of 48
millimole or 6.5 percent
as a level at which above which the
patient is diabetic
going back to analytical aspects
if we look here we know the level above
47 millimole 6.4 percent is diabetic
but then he got low risk of being
diabetic and valued less than 40
millivolts or more or 5.8 percent
that's only a 7 millimole difference or
0.7 percent difference in ngsp terms a
very small amount
so our methods need to be as accurate as
they can be so we don't misdiagnose
these individuals
the same difference here we can see
implementation
our methods need to be precise because
if you see if a cv of less of more than
two percent is found we run the risk of
actually misdiagnosing diabetes
because if you're a cv of four percent
you met they will over overlap the
diabetic range and those at low risk
so accuracy and implicition are
important
and clinically
we actually now recognize
that we can be more or less stringent
with patients
we should be more stringent if there is
uh a risk
of developing long-term complications
if the z duration is is is low
we need to be
newly diagnosed even more stringent
whereas somebody who had diabetes
sometimes
we can actually then fine-tune that
treatment
if life expectancy is long
we need to be more stringent so we could
stop developing long-term complications
if the individual is old then we can we
can relax slightly and give the patient
slightly more freedom
to actually have their life and enjoy it
as they should as it should do so we now
know
that we should actually be treating
individuals
with the diabetes control
talk about impact
well we have all suffered from covert 19
over the last 18 months
but patients with diabetes have suffered
even more
we know that older people
had increased
mortality with covid19
but when we look at people with diabetes
you can see that at every age range if
you were diabetic no matter what kind of
diabetes you had you had an increased
risk of death
if you had covered 19
and patients who didn't have diabetes
if you look at this old england study
here at the odds ratio where in hospital
deaths when people who diabete with the
people who covered 19.
we can see here that there's increased
risk of death
of all forms of diabetes but why is this
if we look at this in slightly more
detail we can see that
as hemoglobin a1c increased in type 1
diabetes
there is increasing risk of death
in these individuals
our type 2 diabetes we see the same
again
as hemoglobin a1c levels increased
then the risk of death also increased
hypoglycemia
is closely related to increased
mortality in patients with diabetes
hemoglobin a1c again has shown itself to
be an important marker
so we can look after our patients
carefully in this case patients
recovered
so the values you produce in global
scene in laboratory are important
so let's look at the quality aspects
how well are we doing with measurement
people globally 1c
several years ago now the icc uh
cepd which is a committee within the
ifcc
set up a euro a1c trial
where we looked at hemoglobin a1c
results produced across 17 countries
within europe
using 24 manufacturers methods
in 2018
extended to 17 european laboratories and
six other laboratories worldwide
and we looked at how
well
results have been produced
based on sigma metrics ie
sorry bias
and imposition
and we could look at this as the overall
position
of individual countries
are
performing how many facts are performing
and trends how things change over time
overall first
so within these european laboratories
and laboratories further afield
we can see that performance is actually
not too bad
there is very small bias in results here
what we should be aiming for of course
is the bottom left hand corner
here where little or no bias and no
imposition
what we see overall
here in this trial is good bias there's
a very small
bias difference here what we're seeing
is poor
but still acceptable in precision
we look to a country
and we see
different countries perform differently
overall most countries perform well they
should lie within this this dark line
here on the far uh outer level of this
graph
most laboratories perform well there are
some outside we can see again
accuracy is quite good
with little or no bias by most
laboratories
overall upper one percent serve a one
millimolar per mole
bias
within the
different countries which is very good
but i must say imprecision needs to be
improved
we've got different manufacturers
you can see here different manufacturers
used in different different method
principles
you can see some manufacturers obviously
perform a lot better than others
ideally we need to identify these poor
performers and move that move them out
of the clinical laboratory and adopt
better performers
however trends over time
you can see over this over the three
years now it's been now it's been four
years we've been doing a study you can
see there's been very little improvement
in terms of imposition
but the accuracy has got better
accuracy
will lead long-term
improvements in imprecision
you can see that some countries are
improving
probably because they're replacing poor
performers you can see here between 19
so 2016 2017 2018 there's been continual
improvement
in the performance in turkey
and now they're almost almost beyond the
black line here
showing that their performance is
acceptable
we can use the same kind of sigma
metrics look at the cap survey we looked
at earlier we can compare 2014 and 2018.
so if you look at the sigma metrics we
can see here again the two sigma line is
is we're aiming for and
that's the
large number of
results are lying outside this dark
line
down in 2014
you move swiftly forward to 2018
as you can see there's been a marked
improvement you can see here from the
star
that the overall mean in 2014 was way
outside the black line here aiming for
but by 2018 a star is just crept in the
bottom right hand corner
and how has this been happening well
we can see from the well you can't
directly see but overall we have lost
poor performing methods
and actually replaced them with better
performing methods
and this is the way forward we need to
say to manufacturers you either improve
the method or we move to something
different
so where are we
i look at this the evolution of the
improvement i want to see in clinical
practice
we have the discovery of a new
hemoglobin fraction
the recognition of this new fraction in
clinical medicine
the large groundbreaking trials of the
dcct and type 1 diabetics and the uk pds
in patients with type 2 diabetes
standardization of results to the isc
calibration
and these standardization have allowed
us now to set targets for patients with
diabetes
over type 1 diabetes have a type 2
diabetes
and standardization has now allowed us
also to use hemoglobin a1c with
diagnosis
and hopefully with this tool we can
start diagnosing diabetics far earlier
in the disease process and we hopefully
could stop long-term complications
and we also now recognize that
global targets are not right for
everybody
and that recognition of individual
variation is such that we now have
individual treatment goals
we must look at this as being the way
forward
we look at individual patients when we
empower them to look after the disease
and we should recognize that in what
we're doing and setting individual
treatment goals for individual patients
thank you
well thank you professor john for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
great to see the big improvement in bias
over the years for the hba1c assays what
do you think is required for there to be
as big an improvement in the precision
between methods
thank you for this question
um
i think that
the
bias
will drive
improvement in precision in the long
term
but it's really down to
manufacturers now to look at their
methods and actually look at what they
can do to improve their own
individual impositions especially when
it comes to batch to batch variation in
in reagents
also is down to individual laboratories
to look at the within uh the iqc and how
they control their systems so it is it
will be i think in the future uh a joint
approach from laboratories
but i think mainly from manufacturers
to look at their
their own methods and what they can do
to improve that imposition
but
calibration with a true standard will
help them to achieve this this goal
thank you
um next question i am still confused by
the terms harmonization and
standardization can you explain this
once more
yes certainly um harmonization is
something which is not unusual
in the board of medicine
it is when we don't have a true standard
we assign a value to a material
sometimes an arbitrary number
and then we use that to calibrate our
systems
so that you bring the results
to a target
usually that target isn't the true value
because we do not have a means to assess
that true value
standardization is when we have a true
calibration material a true standard to
which we can actually set our target
goal to
and then we can bring all results to
that true value that gives us the
accurate result for the thing we want to
measure
so
harmonization is bringing results
together
to an arbitrary number
where standardization is bringing
results to a true
accurate
correct result
all right thank you
next question
will the ngsp determination be changed
to ifcc measurements in the future due
to the interferent effect you mentioned
well that is very much of a
country by country decision
and also organizations within that
country
europe as a whole
has mainly switched to ifcc reporting
numbers
manufacturers worldwide
use the ifcc
laboratory network
to calibrate their equipment
but when report when standards are
provided to manufacturers they're given
the ifcc or the si units and also ngsp
values which are assigned by using the
um
the
the equation that relates the two
systems
um so
the calibrations that manufacture user
primarily using si units
um ngsp units that are out there
are calibrated back from that
um
why why would you want to calibrate back
to a number that you know is wrong
well some people think
that
they have to relate this back to the
dcct study or the uk pds
uh trials that happened many many years
ago
and possibly have little relevance in
modern day clinical practice
so
will it change
i think it should uh but again that's
down to individual
countries and also individual
uh scientific organizations within those
countries
okay
uh next question why do you think that
less than half the people who have
diabetes are diagnosed and how can more
people be assessed
should the hba1c testing be mandatory at
an early age when treatments are
available
yeah it's unfortunate that the large
number of individuals who have
undiagnosed diabetes
tend to be in the countries where they
have little or little resources to
actually try to identify
this
this disease
um
in asia and and africa etc um and of
course the incidents in those areas are
actually quite high
in since diabetes in asia is one of the
highest in the world
but of course the problem or the issue
with
type 2 diabetes is that
the symptoms develop very slowly
and that you can be quite a long way
into the disease before symptoms
actually arise
screening as you as you pointed out with
him goblin i want to see
may be a way forward in looking at the
disease prevalence and identifying these
early
but as i say
many many of these individuals who are
suffering from type 2 diabetes are in
parts of the world where screening with
hemoglobin a1c
is probably difficult or unlikely to
happen
right thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question
what is the status of the use of
individualized treatment based on the
patient disease profile
that's interesting because this is
something which
in clinical medicine we have been trying
trying to persuade our patients to do
for a number of years in all different
kinds of disease states
and in diabetes we have been very
successful
in engaging individuals with diabetes
to empower themselves to actually take
on the disease and treat it themselves
so
so that they have um so
glucose monitoring devices they have
pens to inject their their insulin and
they actually can look at how they feel
what the glucose is and then fine-tune
their their um
they click the insulin regime
for themselves
now that has helped us actually
to
enable people to actually control the
glycemia far better
but we have to assess individual
treatment regimes
as i said in the talk that if you've got
somebody who is newly diagnosed with a
long time
expected life expectancy
with type 2 diabetes then you think
yourself
they may suffer complications
therefore we need to try and get that
glucose values down
to a good maintained level
but if somebody who's had diabetes for
many many years who understands possibly
their diabetes and what is right for
them
and also possibly
their lifespan is less
than uh
their older netherlands is shorter
they may not have the time to develop
the complications
that arise in diabetes so we can give
them slightly
less strict regimes to follow so that
they can enjoy
some of the things they may enjoy doing
because they will not have the time to
develop the complications so you've got
to really look at the patient in front
of you in your clinic
assess their needs assess what the
complications may be for them
in the long term
and then adjust
that regime to actually treat them as an
individual
all right thank you
well thank you professor john do you
have any final comments for our audience
well just thank you all for listening i
hope you found the
um the presentation of interest it is
very important and i think that
this the message we need here is that
you need to understand standardization
because until you understand the
standardization of hemoglobin you want
to see
is difficult for you in different
countries to draw up guidelines
for our patients and for clinicians and
laboratories
and i will say that thank you very much
for you interesting questions some
difficult
but i enjoyed answering them
and i'm sure that if you wish to ask
more questions
in the chat then we will do our best to
actually answer every question that
comes to us
thank you for your attention
thank you again professor john for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye